salve a tutti vi racconterò oggi di come
partendo da perugia abbiamo portato la
scienza nei musei europei studiando
centinaia di opere d'arte per svelarne i
segreti contenuti all'interno della
materia quando vediamo un oggetto d'arte
dobbiamo pensare che a un miscuglio
incredibile specialissimo di composti
chimici di materiali materiali che sono
stati manipolati dall'artista prima ma
poi anche lentamente dal tempo e che
riescono a rappresentare l'immagine
l'idea dell'artista adesso è la
trasmetteranno nel futuro quindi se
pensate alla potenza di un lavoro
interdisciplinare dove insieme alla
storico dell'arte al restauratore
l'archeologo c'è anche uno scienziato
dei materiali questo dà la possibilità
di svelare segreti inaspettati sul
metodo di creazione di un'opera d'arte
da parte dell'artista ma anche sulla
storia dell'oggetto nel tempo e non meno
importante sulla conservazione di questo
oggetto vediamo un esempio di questo
connubio arte scienza nel dipinto che
vedete in verde è un prato fiorito di
vincent van gogh nel dipinto nel 1887
una radiografia in passato aveva
rivelato un volto questo volto oggi
grazie a misure a luce di sincrotrone
stato dettagliato in modo magnifico ne
vediamo il colore addirittura le
fattezze un volto sottostante il dipinto
principale
e adesso che lo vediamo così bene
capiamo che un volto in realtà noto noto
simile ad altri dipinti di vincent van
gogh
quindi la storia del dipinto è svelata
fu realizzato in olanda in un periodo
precedente probabilmente intorno all 85
portato da vincent van gogh a parigi
geri riutilizzato per poi eseguire
questo prato fiorito molto più in linea
con la moda parigina allora questi
connubi felici arte scienza dove
sveliamo misteri dove scopriamo nuovi
dipinti ci sono ma non sono tanti
purtroppo è il motivo è presto detto
vediamo cosa è successo questo dipinto
per avere questo mistero svelato è stato
innanzitutto portato per 400 chilometri
da oslo dove è conservato ad amburgo a
un laboratorio di luce di sincrotrone
bene un trasporto di un'opera ve lo
immaginate sempre un'operazione
pericolosa non gradita nonché molto
costosa
altro fatto è che il campo il dipinto è
stato campionato alcuni frammenti
millimetrici ma frammenti originali di
materia di van gogh è stata presa con un
bisturi portata in un altro laboratorio
di luce di sincrotrone a grenoble bene
quindi questo che potrebbe essere un
felice connubio poi si arena di fronte
al fatto che la scienza dei materiali
propone metodi non idonei non adatti e
quindi lo storico dell'arte e
restauratore spesso preferisce rimanere
cieco non avere informazioni sui
materiali piuttosto che trasportare
l'opera o addirittura campionaria
allora abbiamo la necessità di
un'innovazione quale può essere
l'innovazione l'idea sarebbe quella di
adattare questi metodi scientifici alla
peculiarità del settore e a partire
dagli anni 2000 nel mio centro di
ricerca cnr università
abbiamo pensato di ribaltare la
prospettiva se l'opera d'arte non può
viaggiare in laboratorio
bene che sia il laboratorio che allora
si adatta e viaggiava all'opera
quindi abbiamo iniziato a realizzare
prototipare adattare una serie di
strumentazioni che qui vi mostro che
riuscissero a fare questo lavoro nuovo e
abbiamo utilizzato sempre spettroscopia
quindi interazione luce materia sono una
serie di strumentazioni che ci
permettono di avere la composizione
delle molecole sulla superficie di
questi oggetti in modo non invasivo le
strumentazioni sono disassemblabile mila
mettiamo in queste casse sembrano un po
le casse dei musicisti ma in realtà noi
invece di chitarra elettrica o
sintetizzatore abbiamo una serie di
detector laser pulsati a vari energia e
così via
la nostra tournée si realizza viaggiando
comodamente con questo transporter che
qui vedete parcheggiato davanti al museo
di picasso ad antibes un posto
bellissimo
allora vi faccio vedere un esempio come
nella pratica questo laboratorio mobile
che si chiama molab lavora è un
documentario che filma il nostro arrivo
a venezia alla peggy guggenheim
collection dove siamo stati invitati o
chiamati a studiare 11 dipinti di
jackson pollock jackson pollock lo
conoscete al pittore genio e
sregolatezza americano un pioniere
dell'arte contemporanea che ha inventato
una tecnica quella del dripping è morto
a 44 anni per incidente stradale un po
considerato il james dean dell'arte
contemporanea
insomma il nola parte in questo caso è
science on the boat
andiamo con le nostre casse con gli
strumenti scientifici sul canal grande e
arriviamo a palazzo venier dei leoni che
lì dove è questa magnifica collezione di
peggy guggenheim le scatole vengono
portate nel museo e dopo poche ore per
magia c'è un laboratorio di
spettroscopia avanzata nelle
sale di esibizione del museo che lavora
con i materiali di pollock lavoriamo
sempre fosse possibile in presenza del
pubblico che in genere molto incuriosito
e vede quello che sta andando avanti
nelle sale del museo è anche sempre in
collaborazione col conservatore che in
questo caso luciano pensabene che
insieme a noi
decide dove andare a eseguire le misure
questo che vedete un fotogramma che ci
fa vedere la complicazione
il mistero della materia usata da
pollock è il fotogramma di un quadro
molto grande che l'icona nell'arte del
ventesimo secolo e si chiama alchemy
alchimia appunto sono 240 per un metro e
quaranta di caos materico come potete
vedere ma è un caos
diciamo controllato i materiali lo
studio dei materiali che cosa ci ha
insegnato abbiamo eseguito oltre 300
punti una quantità di misura impensabile
con un campionamento pensate che questo
quadro vale più di 150 milioni di
dollari e che cosa si fa abbiamo
scoperto che i materiali utilizzati da
pollock e non sono casuali lui come
colori ad esempio ne usa 12 oltre il
silver e black ma questi 12 non sono 12
qualunque sono accoppiati e ad esempio
per il rosso c'è un solfuro di carne
selenio e noto ludina rete questi due
che sembrano identici a occhio realtà
permettono di avere diverse proprietà
fisica in termini di opacità fluidità
del colore in modo simile poi lo
utilizza qui per la prima volta e
alchimia il primo quadro che lui non
esegue sul cavalletto ma esegue per
terra scherzando il colore usa per la
prima volta una resina di sintesi una
resina al chi dica che non era materiale
d'artista lì probabilmente la trova in
ferramenta era prodotta negli anni
quaranta usata in commercio per
dipingere termosifoni auto e quant'altro
lui perché la sceglie perché la resina
il critica rispetto a un olio
tradizionale un pò lim per artisti ha
molta più fluidità per fare il gesto e
al contempo velocità di polimerizzazione
per bloccare questo gesto sulla
superficie allora pollock che noi
immaginiamo tutto genio e sregolatezza
in realtà nella pittura è precisissimo
conoscitore dei materiali che seleziona
per quello che vuole fare questi dati al
contempo servono anche per il restauro
alchemy non era stata mai restaurata
prima proprio per la difficoltà dei
restauratori di andare operare con
solventi in una materia incognita è
imprevedibile come quella dell'arte
contemporanea
bene dopo i primi successi italiani il
mol ab debutta in europa e debutta devo
dire all'inizio con grosso scetticismo
da parte dei colleghi scienziati che non
ritenevano quello potessimo avere buoni
risultati scientifici lavorando
addirittura in un museo non sito
archeologico posti strani con
strumentazioni portatili
in realtà poi al contempo siamo stati
accolti con grande entusiasmo dall'altra
parte di questo studio multidisciplinare
perché i restauratori conservatori gli
storici dell'arte ha detto bene
finalmente una scienza amica che arriva
da noi dove c'è bisogno e anche
risultati scientifici sono presto
arrivati questa è una pagina che vedete
di codici pre colombiane sono oggetti
meravigliosi e raccontano con dei
pittogrammi la religione il calendario
l'astronomia la politica delle
popolazioni mesoamericane il guaio è che
purtroppo di questi codici ne abbiamo
solo sedici in tutto il mondo
perché perché sono stati distrutti dai
conquistatori spagnoli e questi 16
sopravvissuti sono in europa perché
furono spediti come regali naif
particolari ai regnanti che stavano
finanziando la spedizione quindi tutta
la conoscenza della cultura
mesoamericana è racchiusa in questi
codici che ci narrano proprio la vita la
religione la politica sono in europa e
nessuno gli aveva mai studiati prima che
potete immaginare non si possono
spostare non si possono campionare
finché c'è stato
la possibilità di studiarli con il mola
sono conservati ad esempio qui a roma
alla biblioteca vaticana al museo
antropologico di madrid al british
museum di londra e al baudelaire
university di oxford bene ne abbiamo
studiati non tutti e sedici ma parecchi
abbiamo osservato qualcosa di peculiare
questi colori che vedete così brillanti
belli usati dagli scriba per realizzare
pittogrammi hanno una peculiarità sono
tutti o per lo più colori estratti da
fiori quindi il fiore veniva macerato in
acqua veniva estratto il colorante poi
assorbito su argilla e così dipinto
questo utilizzo peculiare dei fiori in
modo così esteso che non è di altre
espressioni artistiche delle popolazioni
mesoamericane viene messo in riferimento
alla quella che conosciamo essere la
rappresentazione della poesia per la
popolazione che è parlare fiorito o
cantare fiorito e questi codici in
effetti venivano declamati alle
popolazioni per esprimere a proprio la
religione la politica
quindi è una sorta di materializzazione
dell'idea stessa dell'oggetto artistico
bene ma vi dicevo la bellezza di queste
misure anche quella di determinare lo
stato di conservazione questo il caso
del giallo
di van gogh dei girasoli il giallo di
van gogh dei girasoli che un quadro
notissimo amatissimo a un giallo di
cromo che ha purtroppo la tendenza a
virare nel tempo è la hendricks è
accorta di questo problema conservatrice
al van gogh museum e ha ritirato il
dipinto dall'esposizione e che cosa ha
fatto ha chiamato il mola per
analizzarlo siamo andati con le nostre
strumentazioni abbiamo anche studiato in
laboratorio il processo di degrado che
una foto riduzione e abbiamo scoperto
che ce n'è una tipologia di giallo di
promo che tende a scurirsi e l'altra no
e infine abbiamo dato una mappatura di
tutto il dipinto per capire esattamente
qual è lo stato di conservazione in
quali zone
dobbiamo porre attenzione e come
illuminare far tornare il dipinto sicuro
in esposizione per il pubblico
bene questo è il mol ab il mola lavora e
porta la scienza ma anche gli scienziati
on the road e negli ultimi dieci anni
siamo stati finanziati dalla commissione
europea come prima e unica
infrastruttura mobile per i beni
culturali
grazie a questo abbiamo potuto visitare
decine di paesi invitati da musei siti
archeologici chiese è stato decisamente
un successo oltre le nostre stesse
aspettative e se penso quando nel 2000
avevamo questa idea di un laboratorio
mobile
certo non ci saremmo immaginati che oggi
altri avessero seguito le nostre orme e
ci sono ora altri laboratori in italia
in europa e stanno facendo questo tipo
di misure
nell'insieme un approccio non invasivo
ha davvero portato un grande impulso
alla scienza dei beni culturali sia in
termini di quantità di oggetti studiati
che altrimenti non sarebbero stato ma
anche in termini di qualità della
ricerca prodotta e questa qualità perché
aumentata sì perché le strumentazioni
sono buone hanno buone performance ma
perché soprattutto queste strumentazioni
portati facilitano la
interdisciplinarità ci portano insieme
nello stesso luogo e nello stesso tempo
con scienziati di discipline diverse
storici dell'arte restauratori in
empatia di fronte all'opera questo è il
segreto di del mola be questo pensiamo
sia il segreto anche di altre tecnologie
e scienze
quando si applicano ad ambiti
interdisciplinari grazie